before the pandemic
helen walked her dog here for five miles
every day
but now all she can manage is five
minutes
it's the heart and the lungs if i do
something like that i will be
i would be back in bed solid for a week
even
brushing my teeth or stirring a pan that
i'm cooking
my heart rate can go up to 120.
breathlessness is just one of the many
symptoms helen's experienced
since contracting coronavirus way back
in march she had a fever for seven weeks
straight
and has now developed cognitive problems
which means she's unable to work or
drive
and there's still no end in sight
everybody's saying live in the day
and live in the moment it's very hard to
live happily in the moment
with uh no hope because at the moment i
haven't got any hope because you can't
keep having that hope and that hope
being dashed
that's the hardest thing it's thought
one in five people with coronavirus have
symptoms for longer than four weeks
for one in ten they last longer than 12
weeks
symptoms can be anything from brain fog
and anxiety
to kidney problems and fatigue those
varying symptoms have made long covered
a difficult diagnosis for gps to make
but it's hoped that'll now change
following the publication of the first
official guidance
on how to manage the disease it's a new
condition so
clinicians like me have not had very
much experience of being able to deal
with it and these guidelines are a very
helpful way of
enabling us to provide the best possible
care for our patients
the guidance will be continuously
updated as more evidence is gathered
from new specialist
clinics chelsea in westminster hospital
is one of 69 across
england that's now taking referrals for
long covered patients
and offering them multidisciplinary
treatment in a move welcomed by
campaigners
we hope that this will now spell the end
of people
being dismissed by their doctors being
told that they're suffering from anxiety
and being unable to get the treatment
they need
we're all members of a club no one
wanted to join it's thought there could
be as many as half a million people
suffering from long covert in the uk
and while their numbers continue to grow
they now at least
have somewhere to turn iva bennett sky
news